un aller sans retour ces touristes
français en vacances au sénégal ne
savent pas quand ils pourront rentrer
chez eux
je devais voyager il était prévu que je
voyage pour le 1er avril
1 direction marseille par air sénégal
malheureusement j'ai appris hier que à
partir de
billère vieillit d'hier minuit il y
avait plus de vols
qui se passait aux sénégalais que
l'aéroport ait et b étaient fermés je
suis obligé de prendre patience
je suis en vacances
on l'aimé ou chez des amis et bas
demain mais le problème du tableau
billets d'avions alors
on attend la mise en place du
gouvernement pour pouvoir partir comme
le site
il n'y a pas de noël y revient tout
récent faut attendre encore un peu
j'aurais pu me laisser partir parce que
apparemment il ya le virus n'est pas au
sénégal une très très peu on n'a aucune
information
le sénégal est le pays le plus touché de
la région avec le burkina faso
une situation qui inquiète c'est la
population à l'ap
ça sème la pagaille et surtout surtout
au niveau des meilleurs ce qui la fonde
ça se propage ça arrive ça se propage
sacré la crainte aussi on a peur on a on
a on est on est on est désespérés aussi
parce qu'on n'aura pas de moins on n'a
pas de quoi fait on ne fait pas de quoi
faire quoi s'attendre sur cette maladie
c'est ça mon problème
et pour éviter la propagation de la peur
les autorités sénégalaises se sont
montrées rassurantes le présent macky
sall a très rapidement ordonné des
mesures strictes les liaisons aériennes
sont interdites depuis ce mercredi avec
plusieurs pays d'europe dont la france
et l'italie et avec l'afrique du nord
interdiction également des
rassemblements au sénégal suspension des
prières et des fêtes religieuses
annulation par ailleurs de la fête de
l'indépendance prévue le 4 avril
prochain
enfin une dernière mesure est en
réflexion le gouvernement pourrait
interdire la vente de pain dans les
épiceries de quartier pour des raisons
d'hygiène